Ich höre gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschwere führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Bevor Sie zur aktuellen Beschwerden kommen, muss ich noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer persönlichen
Daten stellen. Falls etwas unklar ist, unterbrechen Sie mich bitte. Und wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Paula Dauppner. Ich bin eine Frau.
Könnten Sie die Nachname bestätigen?
Die Nachname ist D-A-U-B-N-E-R. Dauppner.
Dauppner, okay. Frau Dauppner. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Dauppner?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
40 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren, Frau Dauppner?
Am 10. November.
10. November.
1985.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Dauppner?
1,68 Meter.
1,68 Meter, ja?
Ja.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell, Frau Dauppner?
65 Kilo.
Haben Sie ungewohnt abgeholt, Frau Dauppner?
Nein. Ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Sie sind Sie uns?
Ja, ich habe jetzt seit fünf Tagen Bauchschmerzen. Und die werden jetzt etwas stärker.
Am Anfang waren Sie mehr um den Bauchnabel herum.
Und sind jetzt aber mehr im linken Bauch.
Linker Mittelbauch und linker untere Bauch.
Wie habe ich schon gesagt, seit fünf Tagen, ja?
Ja.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Eher einsteigen, bohrend oder drückend Schmerzen?
Sind mehr drückend und dauerhaft und manchmal auch etwas wellenförmig.
Aber meistens sind sie drückend und dauerhaft.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Also ich darf nicht auf den Bauch draufdrücken. Dann verstärkt das den Schmerz, wenn ich draufdrücke.
Oder wenn ich einen engen Gürtel oder eine Hose, eine enge Hose anhabe. Das kann ich nicht.
Seit wann können Sie nicht einen engen Gürtel tragen?
Ja, seit fünf Tagen. Das kommt gleich von Anfang an so los.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzenskala? Von eins bis zehn. Wobei zehn ist unerträglich?
Fünf bis sechs.
Anfangs, wie war das?
Ja, es hat langsam begonnen. Aber innerhalb von einigen Stunden wurden die Schmerzen doch jetzt so stark.
Sie meinen, dass es seit einer Stunde sehr stark ist?
Nein, seit mindestens drei Tagen schon stark. Aber Sie haben langsam begonnen, die Schmerzen.
Und dann haben Sie sich gesteigert.
Sie haben Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein.
Sie haben gerade nur rechten Unterbauch?
Linker Unterbauch, links, links. Auf der linken Seite Unterbauch.
Wann war die letzte Regel?
Ja, ungefähr vor vier Wochen. Aber meine Periode ist in den letzten Jahren immer etwas unregelmäßig.
Verhüten Sie?
Mit Kondom.
Kontrollieren Sie Kondom? Ist das kaputt oder irgendwas?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schmerzen bei Wasserlassen?
Nein. Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Verdauern? Verstopfen?
Mein letzter Stuhlgang war vor zwei Tagen. Normalerweise ist der Stuhlgang jeden Tag.
Aber seit zwei Tagen habe ich jetzt keinen Stuhlgang mehr.
Haben Sie auch Übelkeit?
Ja, mir ist schon etwas übel. Aber bisher habe ich nicht erbrochen. Aber übel ist mir.
Seit wann haben Sie Übelkeit?
Seit zwei Tagen.
Aber Sie haben noch nicht erbrochen?
Nein, kein Erbrechen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich habe gemessen 38,5.
38,5. Sie haben einmal das Hoch gemessen?
Ich habe gestern Abend gemessen. Da hatte ich auch 38,5 und vor einer Stunde noch einmal.
Wo genau haben Sie gemessen?
Im Mund.
Hören Sie sich fieberig?
Ja.
Seit wann auch?
Ja, schon auch gestern. Vielleicht schon vorgestern. Aber ich habe gestern zum ersten Mal Fieber gemessen.
Frau Döbner, haben Sie vaginalen Auswurf?
In einer Woche habe ich beobachtet, dass ich etwas Ausfluss aus der Scheide habe.
Ist das überwiegend?
Ja, es riecht etwas streng. Etwas übel.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim geschlechtses Verkehr?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder schwitzen Sie so viel?
Ich habe in der letzten Nacht ziemlich stark geschwitzt. Das habe ich bemerkt. Aber Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht.
Sind Sie schwindelig?
Nein.
Aber letzten Tag hatten Sie geschwitzt, ja, so viel.
Ja, die letzte Nacht besonders.
War das auch eine Schüttelfrost?
Nein, kein Schüttelfrost.
Haben Sie Erschütterung Schmerzen?
Erschütterung?
Ja, ich meine Erschütterung, wenn Sie sofort etwas bewegen oder wenn Sie auf dem Treppeninnen-Seite gehen.
Ich habe mich nicht beobachtet. Ich habe mich sehr ruhig verhalten. Ich habe die Wohnung gar nicht verlassen und habe mir auf dem Sofa gelegen oder im Sessel gesessen.
Das kann ich nicht sagen. Ich glaube nicht.
Sie glauben nicht, okay.
Sind bei Ihnen vorhanden Kankungen und OP bekannt?
Also ich habe Asthma. Seit der Kindheit habe ich Asthma.
Da habe ich Allergien. Ich bin allergisch auf Hausstaub und auf bestimmte Pollen im Frühjahr besonders und Gräser.
Pollen und Gräser.
Da habe ich auch schon zweimal so eine Spritzenbehandlung bekommen. Das ist etwas besser geworden, aber nicht weg.
Wie eine Immunotherapie.
Und dann habe ich eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse. Schon seit einigen Jahren. Das wird auch immer wieder kontrolliert. Die ist schon etwas kleiner geworden unter Behandlung mit Schilddrüsenmedikament.
Was nehmen Sie Medikament dagegen?
Asthma nehme ich Vianni.
Vianni heißt das. Zweimal am Tag.
Vianni. V-I-A-N-I. Vianni.
Da ist Cortison drin.
Das nehme ich zweimal pro Tag.
Besonders im Frühjahr und im Winter. Im Hochsommer ist es manchmal gar nicht nötig.
Und vor dem Sport, wenn ich joggen gehe, nehme ich Salgoutamol.
Salgoutamol. Wie viele Hup nehmen Sie?
Bevor ich zum Beispiel Sport mache, nehme ich zwei Hup.
Zwei Hup.
Könnten Sie auch die Vianni Dosierung sagen?
Zweimal pro Tag.
Wie viele Dosierung? Wie viele Milligramm?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich kann nicht sagen, wie viel da drauf steht.
Muss ich nochmal nachschauen. Ich habe es jetzt gerade nicht mit das Präparat.
Gegen Vergrößerte Schilddrüse nehmen Sie auch?
Ja, da nehme ich L-Tyroxin.
Wie viele Dosierung?
Dahinter steht 75. Da nehme ich eine am Tag von.
Ein Tag.
Und das war es.
Sonst habe ich keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Und außerdem diese Medikamente, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein oder nicht?
Nein.
Und Sie haben keine Unfertiglichkeit?
Ist mir sonst nicht bekannt. Sonst habe ich keine.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, wegen dem Asthma rauche ich schon mal nicht.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol süßig?
Ja, so am Wochenende mal zwei Glas Wein zum Essen. Aber sonst nicht regelmäßig.
Alkohol süßig.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Ich muss diese Frage jeder Patientin stellen.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Also mein Vater ist im Alter von 69 Jahren verstorben an Darmkrebs.
Wie war das?
1969.
Das ist 1969. Darmkrebs, ja.
Und meine Mutter ist 68 Jahre alt. Sie lebt.
Sie hatte vor einem Jahr eine Gallenblasenoperation. Gallenblasenentfernung.
Gallenblasenentfernung.
Und sie hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Hohen Blutdruck.
Und hat auch Asthma.
Auch Asthma. Aber sie lebt noch, ja?
Ja, sie lebt, ja.
Dann habe ich einen Bruder, der ist 42 Jahre alt.
So ein physischem Bruder.
Er hat Bechtereff. Bechterefferkrankung an der Wirbelsäule.
Ah, Bechtereff.
Bechterefferkrankung.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wir haben ein Kind, eine Tochter, 9 Jahre alt.
9 Jahre alt.
War das Spontangeburt oder Kaiserschnitt?
Das war Kaiserschnitt.
Hatten Sie eine Fellgeburt oder irgendwas?
Nein.
Hatten Sie früher eine wiederholende Vaginarein oder Gebärmutterinfektion gehabt?
Nein. Okay.
Was machen Sie vom Beruflich?
Ich bin Krankenschwester.
Dankeschön.
Waren Sie in Westen 6 Monate im Ausland?
Ich war vor 4 Monaten für 2 Wochen in Mexiko.
4 Monate in Mexiko.
Da ist es mir aber gut gegangen. Da habe ich keine Probleme gehabt.
Ich habe vergessen. Müssen Sie öfter Toilette, Wasser lassen gehen?
Wasser lassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja. Besonders noch mal vor der Mexiko Reise wurde alles überprüft.
Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Tragen Sie Sportregeln?
Joggen. Wenn es geht, 2-3 Mal die Woche.
Frau Dauber, ich habe meinerseits eine wichtige Frage gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was kann das sein? Was kann ich haben?
Ich kann nicht genau sagen. Das kann eine ektopische Schwangerschaft sein.
Aufgrund einer ektopischen Schwangerschaft.
Ektopische, okay.
Eine ektopische Schwangerschaft.
Als differenzielle Diagnose kann eine GBM-Mutter oder Einleitung ein Sündung sein.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Regel? Ist es schmerzhaft?
Nein. Da habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme mit. Nur manchmal etwas unregelmäßig.
Aber wie gesagt, ich gehe da auch regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin. Die sagt aber, es ist sonst nichts Besonderes.
Danke.
Gut. Dann haben Sie jetzt ein bisschen Zeit, sich die Dinge zu übersetzen in die Fachsprache.
Denken Sie an Begriffe wie Übelkeit, Erbrechen und so weiter.
Ja, aber ich konnte nicht richtig verstanden. Ist das Diagnose richtig oder falsch?
Im Augenblick sprechen wir ja doch nicht von einer Diagnose. Die Patienten fragen immer gerne.
Nennen Sie da möglichst noch keine Diagnosen. Sagen Sie, ich muss sie erst untersuchen.
Wir haben drei Schritte. Jetzt habe ich sie erst nur befragt. Das ist noch etwas zu früh vielleicht.
Es kann etwas an Ihren Genitalorgan sein. Es kann etwas an der Gebärmutter sein.
Es kann vielleicht etwas am Darm sein. Wir müssen das noch untersuchen.
Besonders die körperliche Untersuchung ist ja auch wichtig.
Ja, Kollegen sind heute zahlreich. Ich freue mich. Gibt es Fragen?
Hat der Kollege etwas vergessen? Er hat etwas vergessen. Das fällt mir zumindest jetzt auf.
Was kann das sein, was er vergessen hat zu fragen? Sind Sie alle damit zufrieden?
Ja, die Frage ist gut. Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Sie haben lediglich gefragt, wie war die Geburt? War es ein Kaiserschnitt oder nicht?
Aber Sie haben die anderen Operationen leider vergessen.
Das tun Sie normalerweise auch. Ich bin davon überzeugt.
Auf die Frage, ob die Patientin schon mal operiert worden ist, ja.
Sie ist im Alter von elf Jahren, also als Kind, am Blinddarm operiert worden.
Im Alter von 14 Jahren hatte sie einen Fahrradsturz und einen komplizierten Bruch am rechten Oberarm.
Oberarmbruch und musste da auch operiert werden. Das war im Alter von 13 Jahren.
Rechte Seite oder Oberarm? Rechte Seite, Oberarm.
Und dann war vor neun Jahren eben der Kaiserschnitt. Das waren die drei Operationen.
Wenn sonst jetzt keine weiteren Bemerkungen oder Fragen sind, das Wesentliche ist ja auch gestellt worden,
dann lasse ich Sie jetzt einige Minuten alleine. Sie können gerne diskutieren untereinander.
Und dann stellen Sie mir bitte die Patientin vor. Ich komme gleich wieder.
Ja, bis gleich.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich möchte einen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, habe ich.
Frau Daudner ist 40 Jahre alt, geboren am 10.11.1985.
1,68 Meter groß, wiegt aktuell 65 Kilogramm.
Sie stellt sich mit seit fünf Tagen bestehender Wellenformige Schmerzenabdominalz vor.
Die Schmerzen sind drückend, dauerhaft und wellenförmig.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzenskala von 5 bis 6 von 10.
Seit zwei Tagen sind die Schmerzen stärker geworden.
Können Sie mir sagen, wo die Schmerzen begonnen haben und wo sie jetzt hauptsächlich sind?
Anfangs war es im Umfang der Nabel, gerade im linken Unterbauch.
Ok, also anfangs war der Schmerz mehr umbilikal und ist jetzt mehr im linken Unterbauch oder Fossa Iliaca.
Ok, gut.
Genau. Schmerzen liegen aktuell im linken Unterbauch oder Fossa Iliaca.
Seit zwei Tagen leidet sie unter Nausea und keine Emesis.
Gestern Abend hat sie ihre Temperatur 38,5 Grad im Mund gemessen.
Oral?
Genau, Oral.
Gestern Abend hat sie 38,5 Grad Oral gemessen.
Ok, gut.
Gestern hat sie stark geschwitzt.
Die Fragen nach Verdauernproblemen, Dysüri Verstopfung, Diarrhea, Tachikardie, Vertigo wurden verneint.
Aber denken Sie nochmal dran, die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat normalerweise jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Ja, genau. Seit zwei Tagen aber keinen Stuhlgang.
Ja, genau. Sie hat keinen Stuhlgang und sie leidet unter, ja vergessen auch diese vaginalen Ausfluss.
Sie leidet unter auch überriechenden vaginalen Ausfluss.
Man kann sagen, es besteht ein Fötida, Fötide heißt übelriechend, Fötide, Fluorvaginalis.
Und sie leidet unter auch unregelmäßige Regeln.
Meterogeo kann man sagen, ja Oligomener kann man sagen.
Letzte Regel war vor vier Wochen, sie verhütet mit Kondom.
Ok.
Und was noch?
Ja.
Hat die Patientin ihr Gewicht gehalten?
Ja, sie hat keine Gewichtänderungen.
Ok.
Sie hat keine Gewichtänderungen. Als Vorerkrankungen und OP gab sie folgende Anmerkungen an.
Asthma seit Kindheit, behandelt mit Vianie, einmal morgen, einmal abend.
Und bei Bedarf vor dem Spor oder irgendwas behandelt mit Salbutamol Spray, zweimal Hup.
Also es handelt sich wahrscheinlich, wie Sie sagen, um ein allergisches Asthmabrontiale.
Worauf ist die Patientin denn allergisch?
Sie hat Allergie gegen Pollen, besondere Gläser.
Ja und was noch?
Sie behandelt mit Spitzen, das war Immunhypertäge wahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber sie hat noch eine Unverträgliche Allergie. Sie hat gesagt Hausstaub.
Hausstaub, genau.
Das ist sehr häufig. Hausstaub und Milben, das sind ja Hausstaubmilben.
Die Milbe. Und das erzeugt diese allergischen Reaktionen, besonders im Bereich der Atemwege.
Ich habe geschrieben, aber ich habe vergessen die Sagen.
Ja, ok. Und was hat die Patientin noch an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Sie hat Strom, Entschuldigung, Strom, Nodosa.
Nodosa? Hat sie Knoten?
Sie hat nicht Knoten, aber vergroßt das Schild der Rüse.
Ja, wir sagen dann Stromadiffusa.
Ah, Stoma.
D-I-F-F-U-S-A, Diffusa.
Stromadiffusa und die Stroma Nodosa wäre etwas, wo eine Stroma mit Knoten ist.
Sie hat jetzt keine Knoten. Sie hat eine diffuse Stroma.
Wie wird die denn behandelt?
Sie behandelt mit 570 Mikrogramm Eltroxin einmal morgen.
Ok, gut.
Im Alter von 11 ist es eine Zustandmachapendektomie.
Im Alter 4 ist es eine Humerusfraktur.
Humerusfraktur, ja.
Sie wurde operiert, also mit Osteosynthese behandelt.
Sie musste operiert werden.
Ja, ok.
Humerusfraktur. Und was noch? Ja, das war alles.
Noch eine dritte Operation.
Appendektomie, ja. Appendektomie, ja.
Ich habe gesagt.
Osteosynthese und denken Sie an die Geburt der Tochter.
Ah, das ist Kaiserschnitt. Ja, genau. Vor neun Jahren Kaiserschnitt.
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff für Kaiserschnitt?
Sectium.
Sectium, Sie kennen alle Fachbegriffe. Sectium.
Also drei Operationen hatten wir Appendektomie, Osteosynthese,
der Humerusfraktur rechts und eine Sectio vor neun Jahren.
Gut. Ok. Was macht die Familie?
Familie. Vater ist im Alter von 69 Jahren an Kolonchalzonym verstorben.
Ja.
Mutter ist leider im Alter von 68 Jahren Kolossistektomie durchgeführt.
Also die Mutter ist 68 Jahre alt, sie lebt.
Also noch vor einem Jahr hatte sie die Kolossistektomie.
Vor einem Jahr, also im Alter von 67 Jahren.
Und was hat sie noch, die Mutter?
Mutter hat Arterieller Hpertonie und Asthma.
Ok. Gibt es Geschwister?
Geschwister keine, aber Bruder. Sie hat Schwester.
Geschwister, aber Geschwister heißt Bruder auch, ne?
Entschuldigung, ich würde sagen Geschwister.
Ja, ist schwierig. Geschwister und Schwester ist schwer.
Eine Schwesterbrüder hat, sie hat einen Bruder im Alter von 42 Jahren leidet unter Ankylosans Spondylitis.
Spondylitis Ankylosans oder Morbus Bechterev.
Spondylitis Ankylosans ist der internationale Begriff.
Gut. Ok. Gibt es sonst noch was zu berichten?
Was ist die Patientin von Beruf?
Patientin ist eine Krankenschwester.
Sie ist verheiratet. Sie hat ein Kind, neun Jahre alt.
Ist das Kind gesund?
Ja, ich habe vergessen.
Das Kind ist gesund.
Ja, genau. Entschuldigung.
Gut. Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, am ehesten, aufgrund der anämestischen Angabe und geschilderten Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf eine ektobische Schwangerschaft.
Ektobische Uterin.
Als Differenzelle Diagnostik kommen in Cyphingitis, Ophritis, oder Endometriosis, oder Myoma.
Eine Gynäkologische Problematik, als auch Divertikulitis kann sein.
Ok. Auf alle Fälle muss man daran denken, an eine Sigma Divertikulitis.
Sigma Divertikulitis, weil sie hat linke seitliche Schmerzen.
Eigentlich, wenn ich wieder denke, würde ich gerne sagen, dass das Divertikulitis ist.
Ich weiß es nicht genau. Wir lassen das jetzt mal offen.
Es kann beides sein. Es kann alles 3 sein. Es kann eine Atnexitis sein.
Es ist etwas entzündliches. Sie hat 38,5 Fieber. Sie hat Fluor. Aber sie hat eben auch die Schmerzen links.
Sie müssen sie halt gründlich untersuchen und dann werden Sie, denke ich, näher an die Diagnose kommen.
Es geht hier jetzt ja auch nicht um eine richtige Diagnose.
Wir haben jetzt ja keine Fachprüfung, sondern es geht um das in die richtige Richtung denken.
Da haben Sie, denke ich, die wesentlichen Verdachtsdiagnosen genannt.
Das finde ich völlig in Ordnung. Man muss die Sachen bedenken.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man schauen.
Ich würde, wie gesagt, habe ich Ihnen schon gesagt, nicht zu früh, wenn die Patienten sagen,
was kann ich denn haben? Was ist das?
Da meinen Sie noch vorsichtig mit speziellen Diagnosen, dass Sie sagen,
Frau Daubner, wir befinden uns erst im ersten Schritt jetzt.
Ich habe Sie jetzt befragt. Sie haben Ihre Beschwerden geschildert.
Ich möchte Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen und gegebenenfalls eventuell eine Ultraschalluntersuchung machen und Labor, Blut abnehmen.
Dann, denke ich, haben wir schon mehr Informationen und dann kann ich Ihnen genaueres sagen.
Ich würde noch vorsichtig sein, nicht zu früh eine Diagnose stellen.
Sonst sind Sie auch sehr festgelegt schon für sich.
Seien Sie da noch etwas offen.
Wie gesagt, Sie haben ja bisher noch wenig Informationen.
Sie können sich Ihrer Sache schon vielleicht sicher sein und sagen, das ist das oder das.
Aber ich wäre noch vorsichtig. Ich würde noch abwarten, auch der Patientin gegenüber sagen,
es kann sein, aber wir müssen das noch genauer abklären.
Das wird die Patientin akzeptieren. Das wird in Ordnung sein.
Und wie gesagt, es kann sonst passieren, vielleicht, dass der Prüfer sagt, woher wissen Sie das?
Warum? Das würde ich nicht riskieren.
Dann seien Sie da etwas zurückhaltend.
Gut, ja, aber sonst haben Sie das doch gut gemacht.
Und wenn Sie mal etwas vergessen, Sie haben natürlich etwas mehr Vorbereitungszeit in der Prüfung.
Versuchen Sie alle Begriffe, die Patientensprache vielleicht zu markieren mit einem Farbstift,
dass Sie das übersetzen möglichst. Sie kennen die Begriffe ziemlich gut, die Fachbegriffe.
Die haben Sie gut drauf. Also da habe ich gar keine Bedenken.
Genau. Gut. Ja, wann ist die Prüfung?
Am Ende Oktober. 30. Oktober.
Ja, alles gut. Danke. Und es war ja erfreulich. Heute waren ja wirklich viele Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer.
Ich hoffe, Sie haben davon profitiert. Und wir können uns gerne nächsten Donnerstag wiedersehen.
Ja, ok. Darf ich eine Frage stellen? Ja, bitte.
Diese Schmerzen hat umgebung auf der umbilikalen Seite angefangen. Was war der Grund?
Was meinen Sie mit umbilikal? Umbilikal Schmerzen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel beim Blinddarm, bei der Anexitis, gibt es ja häufig so einen Schmerz,
der eher diffus um den Mittelbauch, im Mittelbauch umbilikal beginnt, in der umbilikalregion.
Und dann erst sich lokalisiert im Bereich des rechten Unterbauches, im Bereich des Appendiks.
Also oft beginnen die Schmerzen nicht gleich an der Stelle,
sondern die Patienten klagen oft und sagen, der hat so diffus begonnen, mitten im Bauch.
Ich kann das gar nicht sagen. Das war so um den Bauchnabel rum.
Und dann sagt man, der Schmerz hat eher umbilikal begonnen in der umbilikalregion
und ist dann nach gewisser Entwicklung entweder in den rechten Unterbauch gewandert
oder in diesem Fall vielleicht mehr in den linken Unterbauch.
Das habe ich immer wieder erlebt, dass es so ist. Typischerweise oft bei der Appendicitis.
Aber jetzt hatte die Patientin ja keine Appendiks mehr.
Oh, ich habe es vergessen.
So ist das. Ja gut, dann würde ich sagen, bis nächste Woche.
Ich sage Tschüss.
Vielen Dank.
Ciao.